so about a year and a half ago I made a
couple of videos talking about the best
way to make desktop applications in C
plus plus there's this one this is the
OG basically talking about how I think
I'm going is a really good choice for a
lot of people but then I kind of took it
a little bit further and I made my own
kind of application framework called
Walnut I wanted a nice clean kind of but
lightweight platform that you could use
to make UI apps for desktop in C plus
plus and I think really this stemmed
from us needing to have a launcher so
that we could like distribute games with
hazel and have a launcher that like lets
you pick your graphic settings and all
of that and hit play I kind of wanted it
to look nice almost like Hazel's UI but
I definitely didn't wanted to use Hazel
I didn't want launcher to have Hazel as
a dependency because that's just crazy
imagine having a 3D game engine powering
your little launcher
I'm sure some people have done that so
yeah that's Walnut and it's just
available on GitHub for free aside from
UI stuff I also wanted to kind of you
know just build it into a just a nice
useful C plus application framework with
just like a useful library and it's all
based on Hardware rendering it uses
Vulcan to render all of the graphics
which makes it super graphicsy
compatible so if you're building an
application that needs to render
graphics on the GPU then it's kind of a
perfect fit but again even if you're not
still works it doesn't quite have the
same compatibility as just a native
application that wouldn't require you
know like a Vulcan graphics driver but
for most people on decent systems it
works fine I think Hazel's UI is
probably a good indication of my goals
for Walnut like I'd essentially want to
be able to make an app like Hazel's
editor in it more recently I made an app
using Walnut called Walnut chat it's
like an instant messaging kind of chat
application using Walnut networking a
networking module for Walnut there's
actually a big video all about that I'll
leave it linked up there networking in C
plus plus anyway basically my point is
I've been kind of on a roll with Walnut
I've been really enjoying working on it
and just extending it adding features
that people have been requesting kind of
taking a lot of the code from Hazel and
effectively I guess open sourcing it in
the form of Walnut and not just UI stuff
like for example Hazel's serialization
library was put into Walnut so that we
could make that Walnut chat kind of
application work but one of the most
requested features since the very
beginning of Walnut because that's kind
of how I showed it being used even
though it wasn't officially released yet
was custom title bars so being able to
make that launcher that I showed you how
does one make a custom title bar lots of
people seem to think that again that's a
limitation of I am gooey thus maybe you
should use like a real GUI library or
whatever now if you don't know exactly
what a custom title bar is usually
native Windows applications look like
this you have this kind of like you know
title bar you have like the minimize
maximize close buttons over there that's
kind of the Native look and feel of
applications on this operating system
which by the way in my examples is
Windows 11. but lots of applications
like to take matters into their own
hands like visual studio for example
looks like this Unreal Engine also has
this kind of custom look and it just
looks really Sleek it just looks really
modern is there any functional
difference really well actually yeah
there might be because you can position
more kind of controls in your actual
title bar if you need to Microsoft
Office for example has that whole kind
of ribbon system in the save icon and
stuff is up there there's an article
even talking about how you can achieve
stuff like that because it can be quite
useful so can you get that done with I
am GUI
of course the thing with I'm gooey that
I still like this is why I just get like
I feel something every time someone says
that oh you can't do that with I'm gooey
or I didn't think that was an I'm good
application like what do you not
understand about the fact I'm just
getting angry here your window is
literally a canvas like with something
like I am gooey you can control every
single Pixel that gets rendered within
that kind of client area and since at
the end of the day we use a library like
jlfw to actually make the window using
like the win32 API we can for example
expand the client area over the title
bar we could also not decorate the
window but I prefer to leave my windows
decorated but we'll talk about that
later the point is of course it's
possible is it easy well yes and no I
feel like some things might be easier
than you think but then there's all
these edge cases that kind of are
annoying but yeah obviously it's
possible we've had a custom title bar in
Hazel for like years now this was
actually first introduced by Jay Jay is
like our volunteer audio person who
wrote the entire audio engine for hazel
he also really likes UI so he took the
time to actually make this beautiful
design that Hazel uses but anyway long
story short Walnut now also has this
custom title bar I've taken it from
Hazel I've kind of made it more generic
changed it a little bit so that it's a
little bit more kind of native we'll
talk about the details later in this
video it's really as simple as just
setting custom title bar to true and
that's that's it so in this video I'm
going to show you how you can make an
application using Walnut that uses this
custom title bar and then I'll also go
through some of the code of how it
actually works and what it takes to make
a custom title bar using I'm GUI on
Windows and if you want to just download
and play with an application that
actually uses this custom title bar and
just Walnut in general then at the
moment Walnut chat is like the biggest
thing that we have just publicly
available that uses Walnut with this
kind of new UI and custom title bar so
I'll leave the link to that in the
description of this video as well but be
warned Walnut chat is a little bit
insecure I'll actually as of recording
this video the server is up and no one
has um hacked it yet but I'm expecting
someone to hack at any minute now
speaking of security though this video
is sponsored by nordpass business
nordpass business keeps you and your
business a sensitive information secure
and accessible it's basically like a
password manager plus plus aside from
just password stuff you know like
helping you generate secure passwords
store those secure passwords check to
see if those passwords are part of data
breaches you know that kind of stuff
aside from that nordpass business is
designed to handle all of your company's
sensitive information like for example
payment information which by the way is
super helpful in an office environment
like if someone needs to make a payment
they don't have to look for like a
physical card or something it's all just
stored in nordpass I also really like
that you can just store arbitrary pieces
of sensitive information so for example
like a physical lock security code or
like the alarm code for the office
whoever you share it with through
nordpass business like they'll have
access to it and they'll be able to read
it speaking of sharing though that's one
of the best features of norpass business
it's really easy to give people access
and take it away like for example if
your team changes and and there's an
activity log that you can use to see
who's doing what check out nordpass
business for yourselves with a generous
three-month free trial just go to
nordpass.com the journo and use code the
Cherno huge thank you to norpass
business for sponsoring this video
alright let's take a look at some of
this new Walnut stuff step one obviously
is acquiring this Walnut uh the link to
the GitHub repository will be in the
description below of course but it has
moved from the chono Walnut to Studio
Cherno Walnut I think if you still go to
the Cherno Walnut yeah it'll just take
you to Studio trainer Walnut so that
should be fine the other really
important thing to note though is as of
recording this video though right now
the new stuff is in the dev branch and
the reason for that is there are still
some edge cases that I would like to
like fully iron out I probably could
merge this to master in all seriousness
it's very very stable and in fact it's
probably better than the current Master
but for the time being it just yeah
hasn't been merged yet okay so let's
open up a command prompts get clone
recursive
we can immediately specify also that we
want the dev Branch one other important
thing to note though is that there is
also this Walnut app template you can
use this template and that will kind of
set up a walnut app that is somewhat
external to the actual Walnut there's
also a viable way of making a walnut app
that's probably the preferred way
actually in fact that's how I made will
not chat but the actual Walnut
repository does come with an example app
like a little sandbox so that's also
fine and it's probably a bit easier you
don't have to like use a template or
anything you just claim the repository
and you can play with it now note that
as of now as well this does actually
come with this kind of optional Walnut
networking module optional in the sense
that you can delete it you don't need it
to run Walnut of course but that's going
to give it like the networking
functionality that was covered in that
networking in C plus plus video and also
part of Walnut chat okay cool so got
everything checked out here's our Walnut
folder just go to scripts run setup
example project there we go back over
here we now have a walnut app dot
Solutions Visual Studio solution I know
a lot of you want Linux support what and
I promise you that is on the table I
have I am planning to do that and I will
make a video about it okay so here's
Walnut app let's just open that up well
very big
um this example actually has a bit more
code I added some more stuff to it just
like an about dialog box you know
nothing too fancy but you will see here
that by default in the application
specification under the create
application function custom title bar is
set to true that means that if you just
run this so I've just cloned this I've
run the setup script I've opened the
visual studio solution and I just hit F5
we get this so here is our Walnut
example application you can see I can
you know do normal application stuff
with it very exciting it actually is a
little bit exciting when you get all
this working because as you'll see in a
minute all this stuff basically had to
be somewhat implemented manually not all
of it though all of this stuff needed to
be considered as kind of what I meant um
and then we can of course drag windows
out we can see that you can't even tell
oh it's in uh now it's not it's out
that's great that works as you would
expect yeah I don't really know what
else to say again normal application
stuff how exciting and then we have like
our menu bar up here help about we'll
just open this up
and that's kind of the Walnut example
now if you set custom title bar to false
then you'll get the exact same thing as
you can see but it's going to have that
default kind of Windows native title bar
so if this is what you want of course
you can still do that in fact I think
false is the default at the moment I
think I might make true the default just
because it does kind of look nice but
you can see in the example we are in
fact setting it to true
so if you base your stuff off of this
example then of course you'll get this
we also have this beautiful Walnut logo
um I yeah just had some fun in Photoshop
and the only reason really was because I
just I had to put something here so you
would put probably your apps logo or
maybe like a button or I don't know what
you would do you'd put something here so
in this case it's just a walnut image
that yeah doesn't do anything in fact
it's part of um you know it's part of
this uh title bar so you can move the
app with it as well
um yeah other than that like yeah
resizing and everything works properly
as you you would expect I'm just
noticing now actually that it looks like
the client area is a bit too big you see
how that pixel is this is this is this
is what it's all about though spoiler
alert this is what it's all about it's
about taking screenshots putting them
into Photoshop zooming in until you can
see like the individual pixels and then
aligning everything and playing with it
being like is that right is this not
using Zoom it by the way this is a lot
of people ask me what on Earth I use
it's called Zoom it it's like assist
internals kind of app I'll leave a link
to the description below this is what I
use to draw on the screen and zoom in
it's very useful because again you know
if I see something I'm like oh that
doesn't look quite right I could just
press Ctrl 2 and zoom in and I can
immediately see oh that pixel's a bit
weird that I feel like that should be a
little bit lower or something like that
okay anyway
um so that's basically the gist of it
download it play it you know GitHub dot
com slash Studio Channel Walnut now I'm
going to show you a closer look of I
guess how it works
um how I made it happen we're not going
to go too deep because it's tremendously
boring and also I feel like if you're
gonna implement it or something you're
probably gonna want to read the source
code and not watch a video um but I will
cover uh how it works so basically at
the moment Walnut is very simple we
basically have this application.gy
um file it's now that there are now two
different applications there's an
application headless and an application
GUI again that was part of Walnut chat
because I needed the server to run using
Walnut but on Linux in a terminal so
headless so no I'm GUI no glfw no Vulcan
obviously and that's why we can actually
have like a a headless wire
configuration I'll probably talk about
that in a later video if people are
interested but uh in this file we have
the whole app at the moment this I I
really do want to change this to be
honest I just haven't gotten around to
it yet because it's a little bit it's a
little bit messy in fact I even have
some um to Do's or like some notes that
say that like hey yeah like for example
we shouldn't store resources in this
application class because then we have
to manually release them before we um
you know make sure that Vulcan has
finished and shot Vulcan down because
these resources are kind of you know
textures on the GPU so thus they're made
using Vulcan and handled by Vulcan so
there's a lot of kind of you know I
wouldn't look at this class or this file
and be like this is
this is Peak programming by Cherno or by
anyone really
um you know this is definitely work in
progress and uh I would like to clean it
up maybe that would be a fun kind of
video I don't know we'll see a bit let's
talk about the title bust off so the
first thing that we do
um is when we initialize the application
we check to see again if that
specification custom title bar which I
talked about earlier if that is enabled
if that's on and if it is true then we
set glfw title bar
two are false so what is glfw Title by
you can see it's added by Hazel so it's
actually not a standard glfw thing we
added that I believe Jay added that
um to to our Fork of glfw which uh if we
go over here into let's go into this
this is the Walnut repository if we go
into vendor and then glfw you'll see
this glfw is actually my Fork so the
Cherno Jeff W is my Fork of JFW with
some modifications such as this title
bar so honestly like if you're a
programmer and you're interested in how
this is implemented first of all feel
free to use my Branch it's jlw with
premix Sports Linux as well by the way
but if you want to know how it differs
from you know original JFW and what we
need to do here to get the custom title
bust off you know you can just look at
the commands that we made you can look
at the diff between this repository and
Jeff W like that would probably be the
best way
um rather than me walking you through
all of the win32 API code that had to go
into this but you can also you know
search for this inside not inside this
uh inside uh let's just go to like Jeff
W well win32 window is where most of
this stuff is uh and then we have this
like
title bar yes job W window hints title
bar um and lots of stuff kind of
involving the title bar uh has been kind
of modified so this function over here
for example this is the main kind of
messaging uh function right it's window
proc these are all of the Callback this
is basically like all the window events
that happen this is like the Callback
function uh for all of those so they'll
basically get put into here and then for
the most part you know there is there
are some details into how it's handled
but this is like kind of the type of
message it is and these are all of the
different event types so you can see for
example when we get to some of the
interesting ones that show kind of how
this custom title bar stuff is
implemented you know for example this
one uh n n c calc size I'm not going to
pretend that I know exactly I don't even
know what NC means to be completely
honest but basically the point of this
I've written these comments here so it
makes sense but the point of this is you
can see we don't do this first of all if
we're using like the default kind of
native title bar instead we just break
which essentially means that we go down
here and we return the default kind of
window procedure but otherwise if we are
kind of in a custom frame scenario then
we have to for example shrink the client
area by the border thickness so that we
can resize the window and see the
borders so basically what this does is
it kind of determines the client area so
the client area is where we can render
stuff and so this for example will tell
us like the thickness of the borders top
borders are handled differently which is
another kind of issue that I don't know
I actually couldn't solve this uh within
the time period that I had I'm probably
going to keep stabbing it but what tends
to happen is if we do actually take the
top border and we kind of try and you
know we're increasing that so we're kind
of shrinking
um you know these are the rectangle
bounds by the way not the rectangle size
so when we do plus equals you know we're
kind of pushing the top boundary kind of
down so in a way you know we're
shrinking it if I run this we get this
kind of classic white border that um
I've seen a lot of people online talk
about uh yeah very very weird and on
Windows 10 it actually draws an
additional native but a weird version of
the Native kind of um uh title bar on
top of that even if you do as little as
plus one here so and I and I did note
that down so this is like honestly just
bizarre
um the reason why you'd even want to do
uh plus one here is because if we look
at this you see that very clear resize
Mouse button thing like when I put my
mouse over this when I hover my mouse
over that top border we see that resize
and we can just click it and resize that
doesn't work if you do zero you can
still resize the window but you'll never
see that icon see I can't see that icon
now now I can still even if I'm a few
pixels off actually I can still click
and drag right because I suspect that
the way that that's working is there's
this other window event called Hit test
and this is another juicy one that you
have to implement if you have a custom
title bar and that is basically you have
to tell the application every time the
mouse moves you have to be like this is
where you are in the window right so
there are basically a few options
there's either I'm in the client area
which is like the main drawing area
that's like the main application area
I'm in the caption which caption sounds
intriguing what the heck does that mean
caption is the title bar that's how
Windows calls the title but I don't know
the history behind that I don't know why
it's called that no idea I'm actually
kind of interested I should probably
look that up that would be nice that way
I could tell you guys and this this
video here would actually be interesting
and informative but nevertheless uh this
basically tells us that we're in the
title bar and we actually have a custom
callback function which we'll get to in
a minute that is used to determine that
you can see this comment basically
explains it
um so client area the title bar area or
we're on a border right which is what
this part does uh obviously it doesn't
apply if the windows maximized that
doesn't make sense you can't like resize
the window by the borders if the app is
maximized but over here we just do some
really basic math I guess you go like
there's not really math but we do some
really basic kind of logic here just to
see where we are and then that way we
determine like if we're in the top left
border which is like you know this
corner basically like are we over here
um and then you know all of the kind of
diagonals all of the kind of Corners the
diagonals and then also just like the
left side of the right side um and the
reason why that's important is because
that way we can actually click and drag
here so you can see that's the left
border if I just not if I just don't do
this
and we never return left you can see I
can't actually do anything now yeah look
I can't resize this on the left side
anymore because it never tells me that
I'm on left and so windows will not kind
of let you resize it
um so yeah that's very obviously
important so that's another really
important one uh those are kind of like
the main ones yeah this title bar hit
test is so so important because this is
what lets you move the application and
this is like a huge thing if I get rid
of this let's just set this to um false
ah sorry false I'm in C so zero
um then you can see look
I can't move this thing man
yeah look I'm clicking I'm dragging I
can't move my window I need this to be
properly implemented because that tells
me that I'm in the you know the hit test
returns that I'm in the caption I'm in
the title bar which means that if I
click and drag I should move that so
this is what I mean like it's you can
theoretically Implement all of these
like you can build this whole system
from scratch like you can basically say
if I click the mouse and I drag the
mouse then I am supposed to set the
window position every frame to the
mouse's Delta or whatever right you can
actually do that I think from memory the
first version of the J made for hazel
actually did do that but there is a
better way and that is obviously just
using the functionality in the operating
system in Windows that makes this stuff
happen like for the windows and that's
exactly what we can do like with this
kind of hit test function so what does
this callback do that is a client-side
callback meaning that back in our Walnut
code inside application we actually set
that so here test gel FW set Title by
head test callback which again is a
Hazel function well a function from
outkana system and then all this does is
it returns or basically outputs this hit
variable here it just calls app is title
bar hovered which returns Title by
Harvard which we actually set inside
um the I'm GUI code so inside the IM GUI
code UI draw title bar is what actually
draws all of that so we do all the
drawings still inside Miami or with I'm
GUI rather you can see like it's all
here again if you're interested in this
stuff just read the code it's on GitHub
no point me kind of going through
explaining this line by line there are
some good kind of debug boundaries that
I've added so for example if we get this
title bar bounds to be active it will
actually I'll use the invalid prefab
color from Hazel but you can see it kind
of draws uh you know these Title by
bounds the top one's a bit cut off there
but this is important because this shows
you like which area is the title bar and
thus what area can I use to drag the
application because the hit test will um
return caption you know when when we're
within that area which by the way how do
we do that well we have an invisible
button called title bar drag zone and
then is just equal to is that I'm GUI
item hovered which is that and that size
obviously which we can um
we can pop this uh rectangle in if we
wanted to draw it by the way so there it
is you can see it it excludes
this guy over here right it does not
include this by the way the reason why
it's not drawing that top area is
because that uh that client area is cut
off so if I change this to be even like
just one pixel to the top you can see I
now see it but the problem is the reason
why I didn't leave it like that is
because Windows 10 it ruins everything
so unless I want to like run time you
know figure out what operating system
I'm on and then like switch the numbers
around uh for now I'm like you know
whatever let's just keep it at zero
which means we technically do clip a
little bit
um but and we don't get by the way you
can see we don't get that thing I think
I mentioned that earlier I'm getting
tired
um uh but we can't still resize
everything anyway so that's obviously
this kind of debugging stuff is really
useful when you're trying to figure this
out but you can kind of see the gist of
how this works right you have to kind of
go through draw every little piece
um the uh you know the kind of minimize
maximize slash restore and close buttons
as well that you see over here in this
kind of top right corner they're all
just yeah icons they're all implemented
over here so you can see here's the
minimize button what does it do if we
press it it cues an event to iconify
which is just like to minimize basically
the maximize button will either if it's
maximized it'll restore otherwise it'll
maximize close button will close the
application that's pretty
self-explanatory and then the the images
uh you know one last thing I'll quickly
imagine here is that the images are
actually embedded which is really cool
because we can ship without external
files and the way that that's done is uh
well I just have a little python script
that will take any input kind of file
and just generate kind of some C plus
ish code of it being embedded as you can
see we have um Walnut embed Windows
window images dot embed and if we go to
that we have a whole bunch of we
basically have these like un at arrays
of just bytes basically and these bytes
make up in this case an actual like
compressed PNG image that represents
that particular icon so the idea is I
export an image in Photoshop up and uh
you know you know what this is probably
good enough for to be its own video uh
because it's quite a useful thing to
know
um but over here you can see all these
images are basically being decoded
um over here because they need to be PNG
decoded and unloaded and then that makes
up a walnut image which we can then use
kind of you know for drawing um and
that's what happens so we have to
manually go through obviously and draw
every button but again the benefit we
get full control over this you want to
stick another button you know you're not
satisfied with your classic you know
minimize close whatever buttons you can
I don't know you can make a whole row of
buttons up here you could omit some of
them you could change them you could
change the location of them around you
could make it like this
right like you or you could be like you
could be like Mac OS and put them on the
left side and like uh I don't know make
them all red in circles and you know
what I mean like you could do anything
and that's kind of the the power here uh
and at the moment it's obviously just
all implemented in applications so you
technically need to modify a walnut code
to put anything there you know maybe
we'll make some more kind of friendly
kind of callbacks or ways to inject code
into this so that you could just uh you
know do this without modifying wall at
all potentially
um but yeah I just think it's a really
really useful thing to have it obviously
looks very nice it can potentially just
make the workflow of the app be more
intuitive and just be nicer to use
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button if you want to see
more Walnut videos I am happy to see it
here and talk about Walnut all day so
please let me know in the comment
section below don't forget to check out
nordpass business just go to
nordpass.com the journo and use my code
the Cherno thanks for watching I'll see
you guys next time goodbye